[Music]
in vegan beef news
this one was submitted by Internet
warrior a vegan woman woman sued her
neighbors for barbecuing in their
backyards Oh in their own backyard she
could smell the meat or some [ __ ] I
thought she was like I could nail the
flesh and it just it made me so hungry
Jenny it triggered my addiction yeah
with someone came into the vegans
background know in the own backyard
smell went into the vegans backyard if I
won I would send her so many like
bacon-flavored camels and baking soda
and like yeah they have like all these
food flavored drinks and stuff
I was Mia oh my god and I would I would
have putting meat juice on that door
handle so every time you touch the door
and let's see what happens me oh [ __ ] I
have a full pig luau dude oh my god dig
the [ __ ] hole in your I would pay for
her pieces online and just have 30
pieces to limit to all pepperoni a
sausage oh yeah Cielo she's a vegan
woman from Perth in Australia and so she
took her her neighbor's to court because
they deliberately come on deliberately
deliberately Barton barbecue and stuff
because the world were one yeah super
important so it's like this it seems
like it's this building that it has
three so she has two neighbors on the
inside and she's taking those neighbors
like a town house kind of deal I see
something like that
so is she saying that since she's been
battling her neighbor since to 2017 long
time she's taken one event to court
several times so it's multiple neighbors
doing this so she's suing two neighbors
she like on the opposite ends and she
said that she's been unsuccessful
because the courts keep dismiss
dismissing her cases because they're
just they're stupid her disputes are
stupid
her neighbors are just living in their
own living
like there's we can't use all the land
but maybe they're doing like a their own
4th of July barbecue thing or whatever
you know like Oh cuz he was just
tapering off but he still wanted to
finish his joke I don't know something
about it just had to come out of his
mouth it's ok moving on I'm gonna show
you guys it looks like you swallowed a
joke like you just stopped the sneeze
because you feel with it's cool and it's
ok the balaam bit sometimes about all
this she's crazy
he's showing something they can feel but
oh he hates everyone in the room you
have a lot of hate in your heart I can't
go absolutely of course I am
it's deliberate that's what I said to
the court is deliberate bang the the
wall at any time when I've been sleeping
there kids were there basketballs
just banging and vibrate vibrates that
this part of the house it's been
devastating it's been a turmoil this
pain I lost right I haven't been out
just sleep she's crazy
have you smelled barbecue vegetables oh
it just doesn't have the same thing not
even can't even smell it
corn smells really good bell peppers
especially with the butter yeah it's not
vegan anyone really destroyed my dispute
right there meat though no knows what
you're talking about
nothing touches barbecue nothing touches
the smell of smoke grilled meat uh-huh
something about it makes me go caveman
style inside yeah so she's saying that
not only is it the barbecuing of fish
and mean and stuff it's also cigarette
smoke the sound of furniture isn't
cigarettes vegan it is vegan
the last time I checked yeah the sound
of furniture scraping the concrete
reflective lights and the sounds made by
pet birds she just needs to be isolated
by herself she doesn't know what's her
man say I don't know there is none
somebody could deal with that maybe
that's why she can't deal with this you
get some [ __ ] get in line but even if
it's not me again TIFF when I watch this
to show you for you they say that you
need to catch a dick that's a nude
that's what the kids say you gotta catch
a dick yeah got your dick huh that's
what kids the sand I'll catch your bacon
you need to catch a big [ __ ] my most
favorite favorite thing about this story
though is that now thousands are
barbecuing around her they just set up
shop in front of her house Australians
are you don't they've created a Facebook
event my barbecue for Cielo Carden
[ __ ] shady [ __ ] it's on October 19
and it says I'm flying up hurt feel like
Arden has a problem with her neighbours
cooking meat on their barbecue because
she's a vegan recently taking them to
Supreme Court don't let money destroy a
good old Ozzie tradition join us for a
community barbecue and protests of her
actions and help steal a card and get
some pork on her fork bring your own hot
dogs buns PS no vegan it'd be titled
like six food trucks that are all
barbecue just roll up in front of her
house there's an edit to this and it
says edit this is a peaceful protest in
all caps they said no vegan nobody is
permitted to enter mrs. carden's early
from mrs. cartons property there will be
wardens on hand to make sure this does
not happen instead of the front yards
instead the front yards of participating
neighbors will be available for you food
trucks will be parked and participating
may Birds driveways throughout the
streets so all the neighbors got
together and they're like y'all come on
down for this [ __ ] 3000 people are
planning to all by
here's the thing I live because they
made it public and they didn't bloggers
from it now she knows the date she's
just gonna get a hotel this woman just
psychologically knowing they're even
doing that next to her home she can't
stand on the mine that's why she move
out like I just feel bad that she
tarnished the name of good the good
vegans she's a bad there's good beats
there is good we have friends that are
good vegan yes I have a friend I thought
vegans were all just crazy like this no
rejoice girlfriend's really nice him is
like the best vegan ever oh I forget
that she's so good about it oh good
vegan there's a lot of them out there
there's good vegetarians too great we're
gonna eat we'll go eat too out of place
and then she knows what I like this
we'll just order me the meat dish while
she gets room but I would say they're
the minority because most vegans are
like this I think I think vegans are
like like they're like the nazis of
today well I think vegans vegans that
are like that are like PETA base yeah I
think they're they're more harsh and
more militant but like regular people
who just shows that have a different
lifestyle
Julia pretty cool but i vegan to like
support PETA like no no fur and all that
I've seen thrown paint on people jackets
like they're hardcore van I wouldn't
fight one of those marvelous but have
you seen Atkins diet kind of person act
this crazy honestly yeah because some
people um they're like you don't have
these barbecue ribs at this place oh you
oughta have these are givers in this
place and then they [ __ ] tell you
about it non-stop and you're like okay
final have the [ __ ] ribs of this
place goddamn put thinit's doctor and in
your life yeah you were right thank you
no thank you
right how do you stop the vegans from
coming to this [ __ ] thing then do you
find guys message your back and just
kick them out no like in street you have
the bag of pieces of chicken oh that's
how you know if they're a cop or not she
can get their undercover
no undercover weeks are you guys I mean
my also good swallow it
that's how you vet them you don't
actually open their mouth that is so
stupid but it's not even just me like
vegans don't even animal like no idea
behind a piece of barbeque and drink a
glass of milk
Oh leather capes I didn't know that
jello wasn't gelatin like the like the
gelatin in my gummy where's is like from
cake and stuff like that so even a
school glue but yeah that's that's
definitely well that's definitely a
horse horses but also mine I wouldn't
eat that either so under the cow on the
calvo go if you end the cows Oh Elmer
they only they separate the white part
in the black part of the cow oh yeah the
white part turns into glue you know
moves made from the same horse family
they're all the same in the same lemon
the Elmer's family she saw that coming a
block away
Lily oh yeah because [ __ ] vegan food
is getting better though these days oh
yeah I bet a lot a lot of local leader
in the badassery
what do you get over there they have
like these vegan meat griddles you know
like a potato maybe multi grain type of
bun type thing and then it has the
sausage patty but the sausage patty yet
but it's all vegans but the cheese that
they use is unlike deities it's like
really stringy
I'm really good it's so [ __ ] good
then they put like this chipotle mayo on
it it's just oh it's [ __ ] fine and
then the bread it's like a it's like a
wheat but Sir bread too so yeah you get
a little sweet with the spicy and salty
other I'm salivating so there will be no
stand enough for at least 36 minutes I
like of yeah
jeez is pretty good it's not that good
for me tastes like an armpit I literally
only have one serving of good thing in
maggot cheese you can cheese is terrible
I think still but but there's so much
that's good like I knew he has full on
giving me something that she's like try
this and it's like banana bread and I'm
like what's it made out of and she's
like lima beans and I'm like what the
[ __ ] that's why I think we're in a
simulated universe that you can connect
somehow lima beans into making banana
bread somehow mmm like doing some
process I'm like dude there's the lemon
meringue thing that her and Tiffany is
pretty good yeah she was bombing it was
made out of bean water what water bean
water bro Wow but you don't say you
can't do the opposite though you can't
get the [ __ ] protein off a cow and
make that into a key lime pie nope
that can't happen no but you can use
what is it call it a seven and up for
like cakes instead of using I think the
egg in the milk I thought you're gonna
say but you can't eat glue and I was
gonna say that mean you know
Who am I to stop you you look rolled up
hey I've seen it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]